et
il est 17h30 mais dans le réfectoire du
collège jean des jeunes à sainte marie
il reste encore de la vie c'est l'ultime
rendez vous pour ces élèves de quatrième
inscrit en chinois
avant de partir à la découverte de l'
empire du milieu parents et enfants sont
à l'écouté des derniers conseils pour
beaucoup c'est un premier voyage sur la
famille c'est la première fois ça va
être bien les scènes saida quand même 12
ans donc faut laisser grandir et unité
police
mais pour farrar l'expérience est encore
plus forte c'est son premier voyage
l'entousiasme se mêle à la préhension sa
première faille
et c'est après ce très serré bon très
contente
il ya un message cordial de plus qu'un
simple voyage linguistique et culturelle
il s'agit de partir sur les traces du
peuple le mans de la réunion le projet
financé par le conseil général vise à
promouvoir la diversité locale à
l'occasion du 350e anniversaire du
peuplement de l'île
l'avion s'élève lentement c'est le début
d'un long trajet avant de rejoindre le
sud de la chine continentale et la
province de canton après une halte à
maurice il faut encore neuf heures de
vol avant d'atteindre hong kong l'île
bénéficiant de son fonctionnement propre
il faut à nouveau passé la douane pour
finalement rejoindre en bus la ville
frontalière de shenzhen il aura fallu en
tout près de 24 heures la première
journée de visite et haute en couleurs
dans ce parc situé dans la banlieue de
shenzhen tous les plus grands monuments
de la chine sont représentés en
miniature la grande muraille ou encore
l'armée de terre cuite
en fin de journée des spectacles
représentant l'histoire du pays
illumine la nuit
de retour à l'hôtel bien inspirés par ce
qu'ils ont vu les élèves entreprennent
d'organiser une soirée t il dans ces
très bien ces faits étaient bien on
pouvait voir l'histoire de lâcher j'ai
acheté en livres au port que la chaîne
ce petit et dans ce lit je vais refaire
comme un carnet de voyage personnel avec
mes commentaires à moi et tous après une
bonne nuit de sommeil
le groupe reprend la route direction
canton
la première halte est importante c'est
l'occasion pour les enfants de découvrir
le symbole de la ville la statue des
cinq chèvres
la légende voudrait qu'il ya des
milliers d'années lors d'une période de
famine
s'enquit mortels accompagnés de leurs
chèvres soit venu pour apporter des épis
de riz
ce
mais c'est dans l'obscurité le long de
la rivière des perles au coeur de canton
que les élèves ont leur premier aperçu
véritablement spectaculaire de la chine
et son gigantisme les néons des building
se reflètent dans l'eau et les enfants
ont des étoiles plein les yeux
ils sont tout simplement fasciné par
tant de démesure avec plus de 16
millions d'habitants
la ville jouit d'un véritable boom
économique pourtant c'est des frontières
de cette immensité que sont originaires
bon nombre des chinois à la réunion mais
c'était dans une chine bien différente
et pour s'en apercevoir il faut quitter
les grandes villes direction un village
aujourd'hui mort un village comme la
chine en comptait jadis par milliers
mais qui ces dernières années ont été
engloutis par les villes champignons qui
poussent ici partout cet endroit comme
celui-ci que sont partis les chinois
réunionnais ça fait très longtemps les
chinois à cause de la pauvreté de leur
village de leur région montagneuse ils
sont immigrées votre pays par exemple
premièrement ils sont allés au pays plus
près comme vite nam nord comporte
après peut-être sont allés en glandes à
travers l'inde
ils sont allés dans les régions comme
madagascar maurice réunion ça tu peux
compter au moins deux ou trois cents ans
d'histoire des immigrés la chine et ses
contrastes difficile aujourd'hui pour
les enfants de comprendre à quel point
la misère a dû être rude pour pousser
les chinois si loin de leur terre natale
alors qu'aujourd'hui le pays semble si
opulent vu les bâtiments qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec la technologie dans la
lumière et ouvre ça fait bizarre
plus loin dans un autre village toujours
habité celui ci les élèves contempler
tour fortifiée construite par des
chinois d'outre-mer rentrer au pays
après une vie de là
à l'étranger c'est tour aujourd'hui
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco sont un mélange des styles
chinois est d'ailleurs inspiré des
voyages de leurs bâtisseurs les
histoires de vie qui interpelle monsieur
fang john wayne il est très important il
a construit plusieurs batteries bâtiment
très forte identifié comme celui dont
comme celui qu'on est là il a il a eu
une vie assez difficile et il a commencé
à travailler très tôt la lâche peu moi
j'ai lors de ses 65 ans et qui dit qu'il
a suffisamment travaillé il a construit
ses se bâtit ce bâtiment et il est resté
vivre ici un premier pas dans l'histoire
de l'immigration du sud de la chine
mais les chinois de la réunion ne sont
pas tous cantonais en effet une partie
d'entre eux sont des acca des bourgeois
qui ont fui au cours des siècles les
rives du fleuve jaune coeur de la
civilisation chinoise et à l'époque pour
fuir vers le sud
une seule voie d'entrée entre les
montagnes tout au nord de la province de
canton la vieille porte des pruniers
aujourd'hui les enfants marchent sur
leurs pas ici c'était à 200 ans avant
jésus christ
oui c'est ça le
les chinois du nord et du sud ont été
complètement de séparés par la mer par
la montagne de la demi saison creuse et
ils ont creusé une vallée dans la
montagne reliant les deux éductours
schiele chinois du nord pouvaient
rejoint les chinois fut et on appelait
on appelait chinois du nord les rats
cannes en français et en chinois ces
creux tia retière qui signifie la fin là
la famille invitée tout à l'est de la
province c'est là que se sont réfugiés
les acca et c'est également là qu'une
ciel commémore l'histoire des migrations
chinoise d'outre-mer perdu loin des
grandes villes
c est l est notamment l'oeuvre de
l'historien sudel fuma qui tenait à
souligner les origines du peuplement
réunionnais on à l'histoire des esclaves
à la réunion ça on connaît un peu et
c'est vous avez l'histoire de
l'engagisme chinois aussi donc toutes
ces histoires se relit ici on a un
carrefour en quelque sorte
donc toute la démarche de notre
représentant à l'unesco à l'époque donc
ce sudel fuma c'était ça rattaché notre
histoire locale à la grande histoire
pour la valoriser est aussi rattachée
notre histoire finalement réunionnaise
bourbonnaise et c'est à l'histoire de
l'inde de l'afrique de la chine après
avoir admiré les styles les élèves se
balade dans le village rester très
authentique l'occasion pour elliott de
remplir son carnet de voyage à sa
manière ce qui suscite la curiosité
après une dizaine de jours passés dans
l' empire du milieu les élèves partis
sur les traces de l'origine des chinois
de la réunion en savent désormais un peu
plus mais les découvertes ont aussi été
celle de la cuisine des spectacles aux
proportions ahurissantes et plus
largement de la culture
lors de cette dernière nuit sous le ciel
de chine chacun désormais son avis sur
le géant asiatique la langue la
diversité les souvenirs leur histoire
leur histoire vraiment pour moi la chine
c'est trop grand parce qu'il ya trop de
choses ya trop de monia c'est super bien
ni si trop grand pour 15 jours mais
aussi plus largement sur le voyage son
importance quand tu es sur place à voir
au delà
est ce que vous avez dit c'est peu c'est
plus vraiment heureux tu découvre la
réalité les vraies maisons ont commencé
bas et j'ai pris avec la première fois
j'ai pris le temps pour la première fois
j'ai je suis partout cyr pour la
première phase aussi j'ai eu des animaux
que j'avais jamais vu auparavant
voilà je suis très content je suis fier
de moi j'ai la chance d'avoir ce voyage
il ya fort à parier que lorsque les
chinois ont souhaité la mer pour fuir la
guerre et la misère dans l'espoir de
trouver un avenir meilleur il n'aurait
pas pu imaginer qu'un jour de jeunes
écoliers réunionnais reviendrait à la
découverte de leur histoire